okay okay you back up a bit back up a
little bit more no were you going no
stay there you're on course you're on
course you're not you're fine oh yes no
forward for it quick yes quick more
forward move forward on a catch but I
tired I didn't learn in the ground
before but again
I'm coming sorry it's fine I got this
maybe probably no oh wait wait yeah they
can't find me I'm good so I'm gonna lead
them in no don't leave them in coming
this way no am I hope you're not inside
here I'm heading I'm hearing right me
too you jerk I'm hidden too oh no they
found us I sure AM ready bedroom door
open don't worry about it no don't you
set fixed it you don't close that door
buddy let's get God closed all right
where we going oh he did wrap myself
around a lamppost haha the guy you
maimed I killed what oh it was you you
mean the guy that would be I was so
random guy says yeah I don't want to
live anymore no I did look I'll catch
you you never managed to catch me last
time served this is head height ok not
so am i jumping or walking off here
jumping jumping ok are you ready I'm in
perfect position there's no way not
checking out that lady Oh catch me I'm
said focus I'm focus focus caching
caching cacao how did I miss you I don't
know hey hey hey lady huh it's gonna get
you I'm ready to catch you catch oh oh
wow that look really painful nah I'm
fine ok and jump catch me oh I tell you
how do you yeah it's good I was happen
some reason we didn't actually reach out
for you I don't know why that's ok well
maybe I think we need to go from higher
big jump in 3 2 1 chipping catching oh I
took him rolled though it was her that
was gladly on my bus good land good land
what the hell let's both jump the police
can catch us why are they shooting at us
it's gonna make sure you can get them
underneath and gave them some motivation
to catch us yeah
okay come on guys come get us what [ __ ]
that's a lot of motivation there we go
now that doesn't it hey guys up there's
police officer catch me catch a user
catch me you better catch me officer ah
ah ah ok oh they're allowing hands as
well I think you later date I'm in
tremendous pain said well let's jump off
something higher all right let's go jump
easy try to stay on all so easy let's
see if they can jump that guy jumps he
jumps are we gonna catch him oh we just
missed him dude nice try the buddy go on
jump job he's nowhere near us la Oh too
bad all right so I'm gonna try and jump
out the helicopter into the into dumb
drunk I am NOT you use my parachute
because all that gravel is gonna break
my fault ok well you're currently right
over the hangar so I can't catch you
there ok ok you back up a bit back up a
little bit more no were you going no
stay there you you're on course you're
on course you're not you're fine oh yes
no forward for it quick yes quick more
forward go forward on a catch when I
tired I didn't learn in the gravel
before but I catch high five that was
amazing good job alright it's my turn ok
ok all right thank gods be sir I'll
catch you thank you we'll catch you out
of here ok oh you're drifting guiding it
forwards over a little bit ok so you are
you all right all right I'm staying here
or a position is not bad but you're a
little bit to the right that's a
good-looking catch good-looking I got
you man I got yes water haha it was it
was a close one but you just got me it's
gonna all right I'll cash in it great
here we go good jump look good John
alright how out ok so Seb new challenge
yeah you've left me up here that's nice
yeah I'm gonna jump over the edge and
you're gonna catch me with the
helicopter pick
favorite slide I'll come to it I think I
can jump to the job to this because I
can maneuver this Oh God oh you
should've seen that that was amazing
keep back up back up ma some more back
up some more it's a police officer in my
way he really is right in your way
please move sir here come yep ebrahim I
catch you guys me sad backwards
backwards a bit no you're good you're
good no no uh-uh I caught you you got me
he got me good catch said thanks i'm
just gonna land here protect your corpse
pretty good i'm out oh you missed it
sorry I'll just oh yeah and I'm out yeah
yes why I'll catch you look at you it's
all right i'm on the edge alright and a
3 2 1 jump all right I'm falling falling
I've got you I've totally got you yeah
yeah yeahs forward a bit forward a bit
good catch good catch yes oh I totally
got you wanna kill that was amazing I
think we've proven ourselves to be
expert jump Smith's I think so ok so I
think that was one of our better efforts
uh you're uh you're a terrible catcher
as am i yeah this helps are here however
the Maverick the Maverick we don't make
blade like hands oh they they correct me
as I fell and yet what and I'll just
have a quick just one no isn't I'm shot
it's like a shot like that you're
smoking again I said you'd quit and I
can't even put a cat even ah that's what
it smells like I'm just I'm so shocked
you're doing again how can you keep
doing this well if I just get them all
smuggler I'll look away that you don't
have to look at it Oh it makes me want
to just vomit in a weird shape like this
straight at your face like but then blow
the vomit at UMBC wanted to kiss of
death here's the kiss yeah here if the
kiss yeah there's a kiss okay now give
me give me the death okay out of this
world Oh
you